for many people tomorrow's Thanksgiving
peace will come with turkey and all the
trimmings by some estimates will consume
more than 4,500 calories in one meal
that's more than twice a recommended
amount for two whole days this morning
we continue our series Grand Rounds
that's a practice of senior medical
professionals who teach other doctors
about advancements are dr. David agus is
in town lucky us he explores our food
and nutrition not just for the holiday
but for the entire year good to have you
at the table that's great to be here
although starting off with human turkey
interactions 4500 calories I was
relieved dear that with all the eating I
do I'm thinking I know I'd do more than
45-hundred I'm thinking this one day you
should just go crazy at Thanksgiving
meal I would imagine you don't think
that that's a good idea what is a
strategy so the average person has 2,000
or so calories a day so having one meal
with two days worth the calories is
probably not them that's so good David
and I'm a believer in that I'm a
believer that you know being crazy and
strict on a diet
in the long run doesn't make a lot of
sense yeah you know we're seeing you
know gobs of books eat this kale is good
kale is bad you know eat this and gluten
good gluten bad the bottom line is that
all of us were designed through a
million years of evolution to eat the
equivalent of a Mediterranean diet mmm
and it's not just what you eat it's when
you eat well Mediterranean diet isn't
big on Thanksgiving Day so what do you
think we should do on Thanksgiving Day
before you talk about Mediterranean so
Thanksgiving Day yeah it's moderation so
you know have your turkey you have your
dressings afterwards maybe drink a glass
of water beforehand so you're a little
bit full and then to me the most
important thing is get up afterwards and
move we were designed to move so get up
go outside walk around don't just sit
after the meal in front of the TV put
some calories out in by walking around
so having your meal earlier in the day
may actually be a good idea yeah it
gives you time to walk around and do
things is that you know obviously meals
are social and this is one of the great
social meals that we have with our
family and all of us you know look for
it hopefully of spending time with our
family and interacting but does exercise
counter the calories yes it does really
it's not a an out balance like that but
certainly movement is critical one of
the
problems of obesity in this country
which you know three-quarters of the
country is obese is because we're
stagnant all day we're sitting all day
we need to get up and move we need to
use these devices on our wrists and
elsewhere to really look at how much
we're moving and move more so there are
a number of people who have gone
gluten-free in the last five years is I
mean we love bread we love potatoes we
love gluten especially at Thanksgiving
is that a problem
what the data were from a trial where
somebody looked at some new
constitutional symptoms this whole group
of people and they gave them a gluten
free diet and some of them felt better
they said hey there's something here
they then repeated with the same group
of people these constitute they felt
weak they felt tired they had aches and
they gave them a high gluten diet and
they also felt better and so because of
that it was debunked and so there is a
small subsection of the population that
doesn't tolerate gluten and appalled
celiac sprue but for most of us it's not
a big negative on the diet cuz it's
become a big fad I mean people are
saying I'm not suggesting that there
right before not you who have the celiac
disease but it seems like everybody's
saying I'm gluten free like a caveman
don't eat gluten and you know carbs are
bad fat is bad you're gonna see these
trends go up down up down again in the
randomized trials Mediterranean diet
trumped all I heard you say in the
beginning something about the time you
eat is important yes what did you mean
by that so it's not just what you eat
it's when you our bodies were designed
for regularity you know the kitchen
cabinet is a hundred years old we never
had it throughout evolution so people
who graze that is grab an apple in
between meal or grab some almonds in the
afternoon they have a significantly
higher rate of diabetes they actually
gain more way because the body doesn't
know when they're gonna eat so insulin
cortisol the stress hormones are high so
eat your meals the same time every day
and nothing in between
vending machine companies are not advice
you're saying eat your meal the same to
your three meals only three meals and no
snacking I am NOT saying the country
David Eggers for regularity I mean
that's that's it we weren't designed to
graze and just eat all day we're
designed for meals they were meant to be
social
the whole village went together an eight
get together with your family have your
three meals a day and that's critical we
can we can have turkey though you don't
have to have a tofu burger right I mean
we can scourge that turkey and I think
the message and all food is we're
allowed to splurge you're allowed to
have a piece of cake have a hot dog once
in a while do things once in a while is
fine but every day at 1:00 p.m.
moderation or regularity and schedule
and enjoy the holiday all be
Thanksgiving you're in Sona and exercise
right dr. David agus thank you